it was a night to close those curtains
to settle in and to face your neighbors
in Swansea they were bang up for it
are you joking Penny Land north of
Cardiff they watched England dominate
the first half
in knaresborough in North Yorkshire they
were on the very edge of the sofa
in Australis in Paris they still
believed it's the first time million
females in the world cup and I just hope
that we get through here
whatever the outcome we've done really
well together so I'm really proud to be
well soon then after half time it all
changed
[Applause]
three nil kills off the Welsh adventure
and gets England's back on track I think
we can do exactly what the lionesses do
but in the World Cup we can definitely
win it if we if we can if we try hard
enough and
you do do what we do
laughs
[Music]
this past month has galvanized Wales
reinvigorated just what it means to be
Welsh it has been an unbelievable couple
of months since Wales qualified
disappointing to only get a point in a
group that arguably promised so much but
for Wales for a nation of only three
million it really has brought everyone
together the bucket hats Amar raheed you
can't underestimate what the feelings
been like in Wales the last couple of
months
and glorious these nations have fought
many many battles this was England's
night
but the Welsh dragon
will surely rise again
Tom harmonster Sky News